you are a superstar in in in your  support yes you are you are a superstar  you are and you know new commercial for  anybody and you chose to do a local  commercial in Seattle for beacon  plumbing freakin yeah and I was like I  mean this is a guy it's like I know  Nikes on the phone and you're like no  tell Nike no beacon plumbing and see  [Applause]  plumbing problems you need superhumans  you live jobs oh my gosh thank you so  much for peace again aren't you  it was next you all good here so go with  Seattle's winning team and go beast mode  on your plumbing problems wait stop  freak  [Applause]  [Music]  first time yes so coming but those guys  gotta be so happy that you're like I'll  do it  we got to get the word out on you guys I  was trying to get in the community by me  that's nice I think that's fantastic  that you did down here thank you  hey thanks for watching please subscribe  to my youtube channel so they will stop  making me shoot these videos please